hey guys my name is Jess it is the
fourth of October and you're watching
games what needs the stuff GTA Online's
baka DLC is out now alongside a bonus
week to get you even more free stuff
than the free stuff you're already going
to get there's a new trailer out now for
the bikers DLC which will let you join a
motorcycle club grab yourself a
clubhouse and play new modes including
an adversary mode called slipstream
which is basically a bracing mode plus
melee combat of course there are also a
bunch of new vehicles new melee weapons
and a new automatic shotgun and a
compact grenade launcher beginning now
rockstar have also kicked off a bonus
week where you can get new pieces of
clothing for free as well as a bunch of
discounts from in-game stores and a new
premium race which offers up a ton of
goodies and catch for those who do well
next up it's been reported that Pokemon
go is still making 2 million bucks a day
according to analytics firm new zoo new
zoo have claimed that the mobile game is
still bringing in a couple of core
million a day and not including the
thirty percent cut that apple and google
take according to the report back in
july pokemon girl was pulling in 16
million in revenue every single day the
report also claims that the game sees
around 700,000 new downloads a day in
September it was announced that Pokemon
go reached 500 million downloads and
according to Apple the game was
downloaded more times in its first week
than any other app in history users say
the game has now breached 550 million
installs and 470 million dollars in
lifetime revenue given Pokemon go hasn't
even arrived in markets including China
and South Korea yet I think it's fair to
say the game still has somewhere to go
Pokemon goes currently in the number two
position in the iTunes top-grossing
chart or sitting behind clash Royale
finally let's talk about getting you
some free stuff a demo for out last two
is now out on all current gen platforms
if you're up for a bit of a scare the
outlast to demo is currently live across
pc ps4 and xbox one that said the demo
will only be available to download until
november one after which it will still
be playable in outlast to you plays like
langerman and
when your wife are looking into a
mysterious murder where you find out
more than what you bargained for our
last year will be out early next year do
let me know your thoughts on today's
stories head two games watch for news on
Final Fantasy 15 and for honor and i'll
see you again tomorrow